cette année la traditionnelle parade de
thanksgiving dans les rues de new york a
bien triste allure habituellement des
millions de personnes se rassemblent
pour célébrer cet incontournable fête
américaine dans la deuxième ville du
pays à los angeles la solidarité est de
mise
des distributions de repas chauds
s'organisent pour venir en aide aux plus
démunis
nous sommes prêts à nourrir 4000
personnes mon équipe et moi avons
travaillé sans relâche pour faire en
sorte que ceux qui n'ont rien puisqu'en
même avoir un bon repas de thanksgiving
cette année après des mois de kovy 19 et
tous les problèmes de chômage c'est
agréable d'avoir un sentiment
d'appartenance à une communauté et la
façon dont il rassemble les volontaires
et organise tout cela cet éventail dead
cela vous fait sentir que vous valez
quelque chose la nourriture qui nous
donne là où je vis dans un hôtel foyer
et dégoûtantes des sandwichs froids
je n'aime pas dire ça car je ne suis pas
une ingrate mais un repas chaud cela
vous réchauffe le coeur dans ma
communauté on appelle ça la nourriture
de l'âme un moment particulier à
l'occasion duquel le futur président du
pays joe biden a souhaité adresser un
message ses compatriotes je sais que ce
n'est pas la façon dont beaucoup d'entre
nous espérer passer l'eau fait nous
savons que le simple fait de rester chez
soi est un cadeau pour nos concitoyens
américains
oui c'est un sacrifice personnel que
chacune de nos familles peut et doit
faire pour sauver la vie de quelqu'un
d'autre
un véritable crève coeur mais une
nécessité indéniable si l'on se fie aux
inquiétantes projection les etats unis
sont le pays le plus endeuillé sur la
planète déplorant plus de deux cent
soixante trois mille morts un bilan
colossal qui pourrait atteindre jusqu'à
321 mille victimes selon les centres de
prévention et de lutte contre les
maladies à l'échelle mondiale près d'un
décès sur cinq liés au kobus 19 a été
enregistré à l'intérieur du territoire
américain